three two one and let's get in there
this water is near freezing
[Music]
three minutes down seriously I think my
resilience is
and I'm not the only one going into the
cold
it's a huge trend on social media
and luxury Wellness clubs like this are
offering cold immersion sessions
why because bringing your body
temperature way down is supposed to have
major health benefits like increasing
metabolism and relieving stress so
what's the evidence that the coldest
positive effects on our health let's get
into it
okay that wasn't so bad scientists think
there could be benefits to cold exposure
because of something called Brown fat
surviving in the cold is one of the main
reasons we have brown fat in our bodies
a recent study found that people who had
Brown fat which you can see around the
neck and clavicle also had a lower risk
of diabetes and cardiovascular diseases
compared to those without it that's very
different from white fat which is
associated with these chronic conditions
and obesity after cold exposure white
fat can turn into Brown fat I think
about cold exposure is this is a way to
modulate Brown fat and white fat
behavior and can this lead to changes in
our metabolism unlike white fat Brown
fat has tons of tiny bean-like
structures called mitochondria they're
the powerhouses of cells and also what
gives Brown fat its color when they
break down sugars or fats mitochondria
generate heat so when you chill the body
this process revs up which means that at
least temporarily metabolism goes up
within seconds of being in intense cold
the body starts pumping out
norepinephrine it's a hormone involved
in our fight or flight response and it
signals mitochondria in brown fat cells
and muscles to break down sugars and
lipids which are the building blocks of
fats that means you're burning more
calories a study found that the human
body's ability to break down sugars
doubled after two hours of daily cold
exposure for four weeks in suits like
these but just because you're burning
more calories doesn't necessarily mean
you lose weight this study found that
mice exposed to cold just ate more so
their weight stayed the same and in
terms of using cold plunders to reduce
our risk of chronic conditions in the
long term well there's still quite a bit
of research that needs to be done on
that to really solidify that idea cold
exposure is also supposed to reduce
stress levels both physical and mental
the ideas that bouts of stress train us
to deal with bigger challenges at the
cellular level there's some evidence
that cold exposure reduces inflammation
and cleans up cellular trash in one
study ratsa lived in a room at 39
degrees Fahrenheit for a week had lower
levels of inflammation related molecules
and studies show that reducing
inflammation promotes brain and physical
health it's possible that for mental
resilience there is the placebo effect
though a small study of people who took
up cold water swimming did see some
improvements in mood also of note most
of the human studies on cold exposure
have only been done in men women have
more Brown fat stores than men and our
fat seems to be more active so it's
possible of cold exposure as any brown
fat related health benefits that these
would differ between genders scientists
also don't know how much cold exposure
is needed to see any benefits studies
all use different protocols which makes
it hard to draw any conclusions if
you're thinking of trying cold exposure
it's important to know your limits
hypothermia is a real concern every
person's threshold is different and it
depends on your previous experience with
cold if you don't protect your hands and
feet you could develop non-freezing cold
injuries meaning you become
hypersensitive Cold plus if you're a
smaller person like me you'll get cold
faster wait I'm starting to shiver a
little bit that's because your surface
area to volume ratio is higher than for
somebody who's bigger so it's easier for
you to lose heat more quickly experts
told me that if you have a heart
condition you should tread carefully
because it could stress your heart out
too much so remember consult your doctor
and stay safe